I'm Rick Santorum i'm a former United
States Senator from the great
Commonwealth of pencil
what you're seeing now is because we
have seen a breakdown of trust in the
system the free market system isn't
working it isn't working because people
no longer trust that what companies say
is going on within their company is
actually real and when that happens
people don't lend money to them people
don't you know do business with that
people don't trust that the
relationships that they have established
are going to be fulfilled in the way
that the people who are certain you know
will and so I think what your instead of
making the point that the free market
system doesn't promote moral character
by seeing all these scandals and seeing
the breakdown of the free market system
what you're seeing is that the reason
for the breakdown is because people have
in fact abused that trust then that is
not to say that everybody involved in a
free market system is going to be an
honorable actor it's going to be is
going to be moral but what it shows is
that if they aren't now did they fail
and today not succeed but the system
fails and so the lesson learned in my
opinion out of this whole scandal is
that businesses and and and our society
needs to focus a lot more on these these
basic principles of honesty and
integrity and and and trust to make sure
that the free market system continues to
work well for America
it's a great hope you know we never
forget after the events of 911 one of
the things President Bush said was go
out to spend money here we are at a time
we're being attacked and I criticize
them at the time for saying that but is
that what really this is about is it
just you know the most important yes we
want to keep our economy going and
certainly that was the president's point
but it was also a time that you know we
we have to look at sacrifice and service
and we're engaged in a struggle here and
the struggle in this case was the war
the struggle now we're dealing with is
trying to you know write the economy but
there's a larger struggle here and
that's the every every old every
person's individual struggle with you
know who are they and what are they
going to be in and how do they fit into
this picture and I think we need leaders
who are you know frank with folks that
life is about struggle that you know
we've we've sort of lost the the virtue
of struggle and struggle if you look
back in your own life you look back in
the history of our country collectively
the times where america has been at its
finest and we're individuals earnest
fund is in fact during those very
difficult times that's when it's when
you build character that's when you find
out the middle of the people and and
what this country really is all about
it's not in the good times the good
times can tend to be the most you know
immoral times and can be the most
decadent times and our times we look
back and sort of you know blush a little
bit you know geez you know that was a we
certainly the time of excess
our founders in our founding document
have a phrase which hopefully most
Americans know that we hold these truths
to be self-evident and we can go all men
are created equal endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
that's that's a that's a phrase that I
was taught when I was a young kid I
don't know how often it is taught in the
schools today I would hope it would be
taught and it would be dissected and
understood but the concept that was
there was that you had people who
believed in truth that in fact you could
discern truth that there was in fact a
right and wrong and that the person that
laid out what was right and wrong was a
deity was God that there was a God there
was a creator that we are part of his
creation and as a result we have a moral
obligation that he has dictated for us
that was the basic foundation of America
it was a judeo-christian ethic it was a
day a Christian reasoning it was a
there's a merger of faith and reason
that that gave us that we could not only
have to have truth revealed to us
divinely but in fact we could reason our
way to the truth and if it's the truth
by the way it turns out to be the same
whether it's divinely revealed or reason
that wrote a book for you three or four
years ago called it takes a family and
spend most of that book talking about
the founders vision and because I think
this is a country that is still based on
that incredible you know unique vision
of our founders that has had such a huge
impact on the world we need to we need
to continue to remember that the freedom
that we saw was not a freedom that that
our founder saw has licensed the freedom
to do whatever you wanted to do
irrespective of its impact on someone
else that was if you'd have said that
two atoms or Franklin or Jefferson they
would have looked at you as if you were
from you know I don't know where because
that that concept was was foreign to
them that's that was not what freedom
freedom was the ability to be able to do
what you ought to do without government
telling do something that you knew was
in her heart and soul wrong
you